- Hey, I'm Mickey.
Let's come on in.
Gonna get to it.
[bell rings]
Me and a buddy of mine,
we started putting stuff
together here in the shop.
Right here,
we got a 42-ton press
that we worked on
putting together,
and it's made out of
this big ol' I-beam here.
Just getting the I-beam in
with nothing else on it,
I think it took
about six of us,
and there was
a good possibility that,
if that thing would've fell,
it would've killed somebody.
Trust me.
I started off--I heard
that a couple files
would make a good knife.
Back then,
I didn't have nothing
but a stone grinding wheel.
I'd grind out a knife,
put a little deer antler on it,
and happened to
see my taxidermist.
And the next thing you know,
she says,
"Hey, can you make two of those
for me for Christmas?"
So I just figured,
you know, hey,
I can make a little money
at this,
and one thing led
to another one,
and I've been making knifes
for over 15 years now.
I--see, and I love
every minute of it.
It's a--
it's an addiction.
- I'm Cullen Erbacher.
This is my humble shop-slash-
yard equipment storage-
slash-winter storage shed,
so...
It's multi-purpose.
Inside I have a folding table.
I have a work bench I built.
It's got my vise.
My coal forge is back there.
Plus I got
my small grinder here
and I got my drill press.
Usually before and after
I work, I have a pipe,
just to--it helps me think,
work things out
in my brain
before I do something,
and then, when I'm done
with something,
I'll have one to think about
what I just did.
What did I do wrong?
What did I do right?
How would I do differently?
It just kind of helps me think.
- That out there is Ugly Betty.
It looks ugly,
but that gas forge out there
will weld just about anything
you put in it.
Other stuff we make besides
just blades at times.
We made some dogwood flowers.
We're getting ready to make
a lamp out of them
and put the dogwood flowers
at the bottom.
We make snakes
out of horseshoe rasps.
Just take 'em
and fold 'em over.
Shape it out.
This is the start
of a hummingbird.
Right here, we forge out
hummingbirds,
so we do
a little ornamental stuff.
Any time you can make
something different
over at the forge,
you're working on
your hammer control anyway,
and you can use that knowledge
you got to make blades with,
make it quicker,
simple, easier.
It's what we do at the shop.
[birds singing]
♪ ♪
- Some of this equipment
or stuff
that I have
that means a lot to me.
This hammer head
actually belonged
to my paternal grandfather.
He had it when he was working
on the railroads in D.C.
I decided to use that
as my primary hammer
for blacksmithing.
This is a pocket watch
that says "grandpa."
This was a gift
because I just recently
became a grandfather this year.
So, I don't know,
maybe down the road,
I'll be turning
this hammer over
to my grandson
when he's old enough.
So that's it.
That's my shop.
These are some things
that mean a lot to me,
that help me
get through things,
you know,
connects me to history.
And enough of that.
Ready to get working.